le salut la présidente c'est ici que
exerçait la transition
vous voudrez bien excuser bruno belin
qui ce matin un petit accident de
voiture mais rien n'est grave mais il
n'a pas pu nous rejoindre aujourd'hui il
a donc donné un pouvoir salue tous les
élus qui sont ici naturellement et
après 18 ans de senna je reviens pendant
quelques minutes la présidence du
département et il doit dire que ça me
gêne et quelques jeunes et qu'ils ont
envie d'y rester
[Musique]
j'ai donné c'était bien le sénat c'était
merveilleux
le département c'est merveilleux que je
suis totalement eux
voilà donc on va sans plus procéder au
déroulement de cette séance
alors je vais d'abord dans un premier
temps appelés nominalement chacun des
conseillers départementaux les uns après
les autres et où des répondants ce que
vous appelez qui vous est présent ou pas
présent
s'ils voudraient si vous ne répondez pas
si vous n'êtes pas là c'est clair les
jouteurs obligé tableaux étaient
représentés à denain pouvoir
non monsieur guillaume de russé jean
pierre abelin mes beaux-frères et la
raison magali barque a donné pouvoir à
ludovic de vernon isabelle barraud
[Musique]
gibert gianni bruno belin a donc donné
un pouvoir
marie-jeanne bellamy marie-jeanne de la
mise
naturellement et là puisque l'un pouvoir
[Musique]
elle est là rose-marie bertieaux
présente jordanien bus est ce un choix
bac à monsieur dominique clément a bien
en plein benoît coquelin valérie deux
jeux guillaume de russé maroney des
roses
ludovic dubau présent les côtés de moi
je suis très heureux d'être avec le plus
jeune commandez bernstein a donné un
pouvoir
madame dit et débutons notre honneur
continue
claudine ascher alain fouché syllabes la
marque et j'en lis je sois francis girod
[Musique]
parce qu'elle dit elle karine et font
jour 1200 draine matin parce que lydie
numéro 6 bis trio joël pelletier
alain pichon benoît pressé étienne
baillet séverine saper les abbés sous la
liberté à michèle tout ça est ironique
mix le par eux
voilà donc la liste
et tout à fait complète ils s'attendent
de pouvoir comme je voulais indiqué je
vais vous rappeler les conditions
d'élection de données la tique du code
général des collectivités territoriales
le conseil départemental élit son
président lors de la réunion de droit
qui suit chaque renouvellement de nos un
cas plus particulier pour cette élection
il est présidé par son doyen d'âge le
plus jeune membre faisant fonction de
secrétaire le conseil départemental ne
peut dans ce cas délibéré que si les
deux tiers de ces mêmes sont présents
c'est l'argument de cas si cette
condition n'est pas remplie la réunion
se tient de plein droit trois heures
plus tard le président a donné la
majorité absolue des membres du conseil
départemental pour une durée de six ans
donc à présent c'est jusqu'à la fin
jusqu'au renouvellement qui n'aura sans
doute pas lieu au mois de mars et cette
élection n'est pas acquise après les
deux premiers tours de scrutin
il est procédé un troisième tour de
scrutin et l'élection a lieu à la
majorité relative et même du conseil
départemental
en cas d'égalité de vote des voix
l'élection est acquise au bénéfice de
l'âge je disais le président est élu
naturellement pour la durée du mandat à
courir maintenant alors d'abord rescue
les nuls 22 installe un isoloir et pas
de demande
on en mange non non non
alors je rappel aucun débat des
possibles il n'y a pas de débat et un
vote c'est tout personne dans
s'exprimèrent disant eux
pourquoi ce si beau qu'un seul a pas de
débat c'est la loi yves alion
chaque candidat peut désigner
d'assesseurs conçu départementale
chargée de surveiller les opérations de
vote alors sur les manteaux l'a26 il ya
les candidates ou deux candidats ne
voyez pas sur le côté
donc monsieur alain pichon est candidat
est-ce qu'il ya d'autres candidats ou
candidates notre supply chain est le
seul candidat
maintenant je vais procéder à
l'organisation du vote et je vais donc
appelé chacun d'entre vous et vous
viendrez voter et ensuite vous signerez
s'excuser à bulletins de vote aux mains
du parti qui n'est pas encore bon alors
je pensais de l'appel nominatif pur
blues et ah ben je me suis dit c'est une
voie que tu signes
[Musique]
le bien commun tory a noté jean pierre
abelin voici les traits pq a voté makani
backs donc toi ludovic qui veut pour
elle a voté les appels barreaux
[Musique]
aujourd hui domaine à botter gilbert de
janot
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur le président a vanté au
bruno belin c'est ma région de bel ami
la beauté heureusement les bateaux à
botter jean-daniel plus haut à voter
françois bock apparemment victimes
étaient toutes là pour nos pages jaunes
de la mine
[Musique]
c'est pas tout brille jamais tu sais
bien rabotés françois bach a voté à
florence bourg 1
[Musique]
un botté dominique clément
la beauté le président colin
[Musique]
le président
à voter dans la cochlée à voter valérie
boj a voté
monsieur blessés
à voter
il trouve pas ton nom veut dire que nous
allons un peu compliqué très bien marri
vallée du rhône
[Musique]
inventé le domaine de vernet
parce qu'elle dit est pour claude et de
ce fait adopter lundi prochain
la beauté où je suis
[Musique]
c
je me bouge enfin
[Musique]
à goûter francis girod
à voter pascal guité ajouté karine la
faune à beauté
[Musique]
j'ai les boules
la voiture sort demain matin
[Musique]
loto
pascal mieux la beauté unis dit nous
avons invité si bien
[Musique]
amiens 1 go to jean pétillon
alain pichon
[Musique]
à noter benoît princesse
abdou n'diaye
[Musique]
à voter celui ça paie
b
il est bientôt là
un botté michel touchard docteur vers du
nez
[Musique]
nous on sera sûr de tout inventé et
véronique maintenu par un arrêté du
scooter sont exprimés dont on va
procéder
ludovic pour les piments abordable est
lourd
[Musique]
on comptait le nombre de bulletins soit
là bas maintenant elle est alors on
compte le nombre de bulletins
alors chacun de son côté
[Musique]
lydie dont 1,1 million selon le compte
est bon
[Musique]
voilà donc maintenant on va chez des
assesseurs dans la personne d'autre de
nous deux qui procéderont au
dépouillement
on dirait bien mme aubry allez on va
mais on y va alors qu'une boîte des tops
les imac les allongent la bulle pas
blanc lui donne monsieur avoue alain
pichon
non
[Musique]
un pigeon
alain pichon
[Musique]
alain pichon blanc alain pichon blanc
alain pichon alain pichon
alain pichon alain pichon alain pichon
alain pichon
alain pichon alain pichon à l'intuition
alain pichon à pichon alain pichon alain
pichon adaptation non
alain pichon
alain pichon alain pichon alain pichon
alain pichon alain pichon à la fiction
alain pichon alain pichon
alain pichon et le dernier blanc merci à
toi lui de vie donc on va premier but en
or voici bulletin blanc et quatre
bulletins se tenant le pichon donc en
prenant ce qu'il était
[Musique]
vous
en deux le préfet nous
[Musique]
tenez un sénateur batteur vie déclare
alain pichon élu président du conseil
départemental de la vienne et je les
invite à me revient dès la première
place en effet l'étude
à
et bien un grand merci
effectivement le suspense était
difficile a dit y a pas de débat tu l'as
dit mon cher alain néanmoins quelques
mots ma première pensée va évidemment
auprès de bruno qui ce matin donc alain
tu nous l'a dit a eu un accident de
voiture dont nous nous rejoint ce matin
qui va nous y vas nous manquer
évidemment mais j'espère qu'il va
revenir très vite en pleine forme mais
je compte sur sa vitalité son dynamisme
pour que ce soit le cas monsieur le
sénateur honoraire faire alain mes chers
collègues
mesdames messieurs je tiens tout d'abord
à remercier mon cher alain pour avoir
présidé cette séance ainsi que toi
ludovic pour avoir assumé le secrétariat
merci aussi également à toi valérie pour
avoir assumer cette présidence par
intérim pendant ces derniers jours je
remercie aussi chaleureusement mes
prédécesseurs toi mon cher alain avec ta
volonté chevillée au corps de permettre
à toute la viennent d'accéder à la
culture
claude bertaud dont je garde un souvenir
la grande humanité est évidemment bruno
est tu nous manque ce matin tu es sans
conteste un bâtisseur et tu as été un
bâtisseur pour la vienne pendant tout
son mandat sa vision à volonté ton
dynamisme
peut-être qu'il regardera ça un peu plus
tard quand il sera remis ont fait
grandir notre département nous comptons
désormais sur toi pour continuer cet
élan au sénat avec énergie et
détermination aux côtés d'yves boulou
nous avons besoin de vous à cet instant
vous venez de me lire à la présidence du
conseil départemental
mes premières pensées sont pour vous mes
chers collègues que je remercie pour
votre confiance et pour l'esprit
d'équipé qui nous anime
je vais également salué l'ensemble des
élus de
position et évidemment les indépendants
pour lesquels j'aurai une écoute
attentive
je profite de ce moment pour en régaler
en hommage aux 1600 agents de notre
collectivité
je sais combien ils nous sont précieux
et combien notre action politique ne
pourrait s'effectuer sur leur engagement
permanent
je les remercie ici publiquement
j'ai également une pensée forte pour
tous les personnels soignants et ceux
qui oeuvrent auprès des malades et des
plus fragiles en cette période de crise
sanitaire
j'ai naturellement une pensée pour rené
monory qui aura tracé la ligne de vie de
la vienne et pour jacques debout là ce
qui m'a lancé dans le grand bain du
département en 2011
enfin je pense tout public tout
particulièrement aux habitants de la
commune en entrant ainsi qu'à nos
collaborateurs et mes collègues élus
sans lesquels je n'aurais pas parcouru
du chemin
ils m'ont beaucoup donné et beaucoup
appris j'ai raté la troisième page
pardonnez moi je resterai membre du
conseil municipal
à leurs côtés comme je le suis
maintenant depuis 37 ans dont 25 années
en tant que maire un mandat qui m'a
permis
voici deux ans et demi de devenir
également président des maires de la
vienne une mission que j'ai aimé où j'ai
pu porter la voix de toutes celles et de
tous ceux qui battent qui se battent au
quotidien pour leur commune en toute
abnégation ne comptant ni leur temps ni
leur énergie en dépit des difficultés
parfois du manque de considération de
certains mais quel beau mandat que celui
d'un représentant de l'état qui est le
lien social entre tous tous ces
engagements vous l'avez compris font
partie de mon adn
la génétique en effet n'est pas
complètement étrangère à ma présence
aujourd'hui parmi vous mon père mère
d'entrants mon grand-père également
merdes entrants et conseiller général
ici du canton de laigné sur u so ont
creusé avant moi le sillon de mon
engagement politique et m'ont transmis
la fibre ce souhait d re au plus près
des préoccupations de nos concitoyens de
faire ce qui est en mon pouvoir pour
leur offrir une meilleure qualité de vie
de voir plus loin pour en créer nos
territoires dans un avenir rempli
d'optimisme
le justice et de projets c'est aussi
dans l'essence même de mon métier
d'agriculteur que je les trouvais là
encore porté par plusieurs générations
avant moi pareil et la terre faire
pousser la vie comme disait mon fils
guillaume lorsqu'il était petit nooja
ancré dans la réalité dans l'humilité
dans lé authentique et dans le
pragmatisme
plus que partout ailleurs on comprend la
signification et la valeur de cet adage
qui dit qu'on ne récolte que ce que l'on
sème mais je ne suis pas seulement et
rural en tant que maire d'une commune
périurbaine
je reste attentif à l'avenir de grands
châtellerault aux côtés de jean pierre
abelin tout comme aux évolutions de
toutes les intercommunalités de la
vienne le département de la vienne
restera le premier partenaire des
communes et des intercommunalités
cette élection intervient dans un
contexte très difficile de crise
sanitaire inédite est hors norme
nous devons plus que jamais être
attentifs et mobilisés pour gagner cette
grande bataille le contexte national
le contexte sanitaire pardon exige une
assemblée départementale forte confiante
et engagé c'est pourquoi je mènerai une
présidence à la fois assembleuse et
combattit c'est aussi travail de chacun
d'entre vous qui permettra de mettre en
place des politiques publiques
efficientes au service de nos
concitoyens et particulièrement des plus
vulnérables
je souhaite que le débat continue d'être
digne et respectueux et que chacun et
chacune d'entre vous puisse apporter sa
pierre à l'édifice
j'apporterai beaucoup d'importance au
travail des coûts
si on est à leur représentativité
j'aimerais des rencontres régulières
avec les vice présidents j'animerai
pardon des rencontres régulières avec
les vice présidents et vous tous pour
échanger et faire avancer nos projets je
me rendrai naturellement dans tous les
cantons
dans toutes les communes dont toutes les
intercommunalités
car je crois en cette proximité facteurs
indispensables à la préservation du lien
social
je souhaite également qu'à travers nos
actions quotidiennes auprès de nos
habitants
notre présence auprès d'eux ils puissent
retrouver confiance en l'action
politique
nous devrons être et rester créatif pour
imaginer la vienne de demain nous
pencher tout particulièrement avec
énergie et conviction sur la santé et la
solidarité l'éducation l'attractivité de
notre territoire l'environnement les
routes le numérique
je veux que nous continuons à avoir
cette ambition de développement de notre
territoire qui nous a guidé jusqu'ici
que nous réfléchissions ensemble peut
aller plus loin ça faisait des mois
j'ai du mal à retrouver aujourd'hui
s'ouvre un nouveau chapitre de notre
mandat et 2021 devrait marquer une
nouvelle étape à travers les élections
départementales
bien que leur maintien en mars soit pour
le moment incertain je mesure l'immense
responsabilités que vous m'avez confié
aujourd'hui pour servir la vienne et je
le ferai avec votre aide et dans
l'unique intérêt général qui guident mon
action politique depuis toujours
chaque jour ils devront mériter la
confiance de nos concitoyens
chaque jour nous devrons préparer
l'avenir
chaque jour nous devrons incarner les
valeurs qui nous rassemblent
la liberté l'égalité la fraternité la
laïcité la justice sociale je ne ferai
pas de cette assemblée une tribune
politique
je ne suis pas l'homme d'un camp je suis
libre et indépendant et je le resterai
dans l'unique intérêt de la vienne
mon action sera celle du pragmatisme et
du bon sens
merci encore de votre confiance et au
travail
merci beaucoup
[Musique]
eh bien nous allons continuer dans notre
ordre du jour
après l'excellent travail de notre
président et de notre secrétaire en vous
proposant de fixer le nombre des vice
présidents et des autres membres de la
commission permanente et je vous demande
s'il vous serez si vous accepterez de
voter à main levée
plutôt qu à bulletin secret y at il des
oppositions sur cette proposition
les abstentions et bien je vous remercie
[Musique]
la commission permanente est composé du
président de onze vice président pour la
vienne je vous propose de reconduire la
composition actuelle de la commission
permanente à 38 membres
outre le président onze vice-présidents
un président-délégué deux conseillers
départementaux délégués et 23 autrement
y at il des objections
les abstentions je vous remercie
la commission permanente et serait
composée d' alain pichon de valérie
d'auge d'henri colin de pascal moreau à
ces départs dont il faut une petite
coupure il faut une coupure d'une heure
j'étais parti dans ma lancée
désolé vous allez pouvoir vous dégourdir
les jambes
donc nous nous levons la science pour
une heure c'est une règle pardon
obligatoire et que nous oblige à voir la
loi merci on revient théoriquement à
10h50
comme la loi nous l'indiquent